[Music]
with the recent rise in abuse of 9-1-1
emergency services the fcc has come up
with a solution that we think really
works 912 emergency services
an easy to remember number for dealing
with emergencies that are clearly
idiotic or insane let me show you how it
works 912 emergency services hi i have a
bit of an emergency i bet 30 dollars on
a baseball game and my team lost i am
very angry and i would like you to give
the san diego padres diarrhea of course
just hold your location and we'll send
out a diarrhea unit as soon as we can
you guys are the best
912 is the new first responder for any
emergency situation your mental illness
can invent such as
rude waitresses lost shoes unflattering
haircuts mind control werewolf attacks
space flu personally threatening
messages hidden in shampoo commercials
and of course ghost rape
if you cover the bowl with cardboard
your goldfish won't be able to steal
your ideas for the next star wars movie
okay talk to you tomorrow mr busy
so call 912 emergency services and if
you don't have a phone write the numbers
on a piece of paper and swallow it
we'll find you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]